(light rock music)
- Now time for tonight's Hashtag Wars.
(audience cheering)
(dinging)
- To Marina.
- Once you go black hoe
you never go back hoe.
(audience cheering)
- Nice, points, genius,
(dinging)
well done.
Jesse.
- Jizz Aldrin.
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
That man is a national hero!
Points!
- He was a dick to me
once, it doesn't matter.
- Okay, alright, yeah.
(dinging)
Yes, Todd.
- Niptune.
- [Chris] Yes.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Points.
Jesse.
- Hot Carl Sagan.
(audience laughing)
(Chris laughing)
(dinging)
- [Chris] Steve.
- My wife starting to
grow her Winter bush.
(Chris laughing)
(audience cheering)
- [Chris] Points, points.
(dinging)
Brent.
- It's Fall because the love
of my life is getting married
and I'm saying that for you.
- Aw.
(audience awing)
- [Jessie] Aw.
- I'm a nice guy.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
- Brent Morin.
- Every white guy starting
to dress more and more
like Harry Styles.
- [Chris] Yes points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Steve.
- I have more time to smoke pot
because my kids go to school.
- Yay, points!
(audience appluading)
(dinging)
Jessie, go ahead.
- It's Fall because I caught
Jason Biggs (bleep) a pumpkin pie.
- [Chris] Hey!
(audience cheering)
(dinging)
- [Chris] Megan Neuringer.
- Ask Jeeves if it's time for my medicine.
- Okay, good, points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Steve.
- My space is a tiny
room in a nursing home.
(Chris laughing)
(audience laughing)
- Which you belong in for even
referencing MySpace, points.
(dinging)
Yes, Megan.
- All of my friend-sters are dead.
- Okay, points, good.
(audience groaning)
(dinging)
Nick.
- ESPN Go, get off my lawn!
- Points, yeah, definitely.
(dinging)
Steve.
- Schindler's List.
- [Chris] Oh, God.
(audience groaning)
- [Steve] It's like Craigslist.
(audience laughing)
- Steve, it's Rosh Hashanah, we're...
- What's that?
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
- [Chris] Julien.
- Reese's Penis Butter Cups.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
- Nikki.
- Bone Me.
- Yes, points.
(audience groaning)
(dinging)
- Michael.
- Penis alla vodka.
- [Chris] Yes, points.
(audience laughing).
(dinging)
Julien.
- The Whopper.
(audience laughing)
- Yep, hope so, yeah, points.
(dinging)
Nikki.
- Six and a half inch sub, toasted.
- Okay, good, points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Julien.
- Full Monte Cristo.
- Yes, perfect, points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Michael.
- Apple pie a la chode.
- [Chris] Yeah, points.
(audience laughing)
(dinging)
Yow, God damnit!
(Chris groaning)
(audience groaning)